okay
uh welcome to people joining this live
stream we're starting a little late
um we actually have a triple header of
live streams here
um this is language completeness and
consistency then i'm doing
a history of science and technology q a
and then we have a language development
uh meeting after that
i'm being kept very busy because uh um
i'm operating with people filling in
for scheduling for me and the people who
are filling in are overqualified and
they're making me
more busy than i usually would be so
anyway there it is
um all right let's start off here
excluded and include
what's an included yes that's just a
typo
the symbol is correct in the system
okay okay
so i i was going to write draft ref
pages and
i got busy with something sorry so they
aren't but
um we discussed this last time right
we discussed this last time right and i
i wanted to point out that these
having these options is useful
independently
of the edge case of system and
how do we distinguish system uh
things right so for example you can say
you know
included context goes to automatic which
will only save things in the current
context
or you know included context goes to
you know my contact spectic star which
will only save
everything in a family of related
contexts what about all
that's the default okay okay
so right so it should really be
inherited i mean sorry
automatic rather than inherited for the
the current context
only um
i suppose it could be inherited that
strikes me as a bit
strange but i i can't quantify that off
the top
of my head right i agree it's not quite
right
inherited but okay so
didn't we also discuss the option of uh
all the contexts that appear literally
in the given expression oh right yes
that's why it was automatic so for full
definition you just give
a symbol or uh you know right
but for some other functions you might
have a whole expression and then
automatic picks
up all the contexts that appear
literally
in the expression you gave it
okay
um okay i mean sounds fine
okay what is the question here right so
then there was the question of should
system
be in the default excluded list
and then you had this idea of well we
should somehow
mark down values that are
created after a certain point and only
pull in those and so that's all very
complicated and not
not for to you know go ahead we're going
to say right so tom is here to to
discuss the practicality of that
because he wasn't here last time so
um okay well the idea is pretty simple i
mean the idea is
to be able to know when an assignment
was made
and to be able to decide that assignment
was made during initialization
and it'll be remade you know by another
system or that thing was made
i mean it's really what is the
provenance of the assignment
i mean you know is it conceivable in the
down value list
or in some aspect of a symbol we could
actually store metadata associated with
the assignment
down values are metadata in a way um i
know but they don't store the time it
was made or the
or the could could yeah i mean sure
it could do all of this um
i mean if you have a tight loop a
function that's storing a million values
it's not something you're going to want
but in the case i mean if
if there was a way of storing
even you know the first down i don't
know i don't know
exactly what the right heuristic is but
but a way of i mean perhaps something
you could switch off or or
i mean something which gives you a sense
of
this thing was added by the user on
purpose and should be preserved
this thing was added as part of
initialization and will be regenerated
because that's the thing we need to
understand
there's no reason to transport a giant
pile of random initialization stuff
that you know let's say you're sending
code to somebody
right no reason to
explicitly send code the person's going
to have anyway
right i mean right so i would say
they're they're sort of like
you might load paclets later i mean the
down value it's not just question of
the time it was loaded at it's not like
after a certain period you you can
switch over and it's all
user stuff i mean that's that's not hard
no that's right you're right that's not
correct
but but this whole question of is it
user added
or is it a system thing that will be
automatically replaced that's what we
need to know
i mean that problem came in came into
being when
when we started to use top level orphan
code for for ourselves right and so now
we have this
ugly read protected attribute to hide
our own mess and so i think it's yes i
mean
originally we promised that user code
would come first in the evaluation
that is no longer true and i think the
whole this whole question
a lot of these questions we should
address at some point well okay so
one of the things you're suggesting is
that rather than using read protected
as a proxy indication of system added
code
that maybe we should have a more
explicit way of indicating that yeah
because read protect it doesn't
distinguish between our code and user
well neither does sort of clear and
things like that you might want just to
clear
your additions as well
well right okay i think i think what we
would need is
um like a start
system uh
mode right a function that says okay
mark all these things
as system things and they go in a
separate table that's accessed less you
know
last but i don't know
well i mean the other point is look look
protected two things there i mean
reproject is a symbol-based thing
what we want is an assignment based way
of indicating
these assignments for this thing came
from the system
these were user added
right read protected applies only to a
whole symbol
yeah that's that's yes
but we also want this new attribute
to influence the order of of
matching right so do we really want to
do that that's i'm not sure we want it
that's a massive change okay i mean my
original
suggestion many years ago uh which was
probably too complicated is to have two
symbol tables one for us and one for
users
so so we had a clear distinction between
the two cases
i think the problem is that us is more
complicated
what about a third-party package
how us is us
well i mean there's other ways than
having two symbol tables i mean you can
just mark all the symbols as being an
us symbol or no no but we're saying it
isn't a symbol it's not the whole symbol
oh no i i'm agreeing but i'm just saying
the two symbol table thing isn't
right but i'd like to point out the us
it's like oh we have an experimental
project that happens to be done by a
person at our company
is that us is that not us you know what
i'm saying i don't think it's a
clear distinction but also i'm
forgetting what the what the example was
but the the this came up because of
system symbols
that are expected to be cut
used you know given that down values or
own values
by users or format values or something
like that
or derivative are both examples right
derivative might be the one that i was
thinking of yeah
yes okay
look first thing is get included context
says story context working that's fine
we're you know
we it's all agreed you know pack and
send
the next issue is
uh to
you know what are our objectives we want
to cut the crud out of the autocompletes
we want to prevent safe definitions from
saving
irrelevant stuff those are the two known
objectives other objectives
i think those are the two certainly
those are the two main ones
okay fine all right so
for okay so
for the autocomplete
so certainly we want to complete
everything that's in systems so that's
an argument that we shouldn't consider
system and included you know an internal
context in the sense of
well absolutely but yeah
i'd like to point out that both of those
uses are a per symbol rather than a per
assignment use
right i mean there's a different thing
which is like a reset
you know can we roll things back you
know let's say we have a kernel and we i
mean honestly
in the modern world you know
it's like the cost of restarting a
kernel
you know in a container and whatever and
whatever whatever should be low enough
you just don't care
if there's something if you don't like
what's there throw it away and start
again
rather than worrying about micro
resetting you know
clearing these five definitions here
type thing
that makes sense
so i think we're not hearing an argument
i mean i think it would be interesting
to be able to tell what was a user added
change versus systematic change but i'm
not sure it's worth it
and and now really the question is
you know i don't i think we just messed
up our heuristics
for the autocompletes and those can be
fixed
so long as we know look the main issue
is was a context
brought in by a user or was it entrained
by some
complicated chain of paclet loads
that was not under you know what the
user doesn't care about
i i look i don't understand why it isn't
really quite straightforward to decide
what to put in the autocompletes
basically to my mind if it's not on the
context path it probably shouldn't be in
the autocomplete
you see what i'm saying when when should
a symbol i don't know whether we have
the right people to discuss this
when should a symbol be in the
autocomplete when it uh when it isn't on
the context
well well well symbols i think are only
around the
uh in the autocomplete when naked
symbols are only ever
on the completion list if they are
i know but that that there are qualified
things with all kinds of look
if i just well yeah well that's because
that's because
the right that's because uh
because what it's because it's bugs
probably it's not bugs
right it's it's it's because because the
system is
designed to allow you to also type in
fully qualified
symbols i understand but the whole point
is my point is
we don't want to offer spelunking by
default
right i don't think we should offer it
by default but we have the wrong set of
people here to discuss this i don't
think we should put in the list of
autocompletes
symbols most of the time unless you're
explicitly using contacts you know
unless it knows that you use that
context
i don't think we should offer maybe
that's the heuristic
if you use that context once then
it will in that session for example then
it will continue showing you auto
completes for that context
otherwise it will open what do you mean
use that context
you it was a context not on your context
path
so i explicitly typed in you know
algebra back tick
you know i don't know whether what
what's a good what's a good um
uh what what what's a good context that
somebody knows
um internal i don't know what's a good
okay there we go there we go okay all
right so this is now auto completing a
context name
right which i suppose is okay
all right so let's say i do that and i
type a
all right fine yeah i know i would
expect this right
yeah this is right there's nothing wrong
with this but now
let's take abs square
okay well that's probably correct right
i mean it does not so far as i know the
symbols only show
symbols only show up in auto completions
if they're on dollar context path
or so if you did less less
internal back tick
or no other way don't do that no i don't
want
or less less experimental right and then
you'll get the experimental things and
okay look maybe there isn't a problem
here i mean maybe i see this problem
more than most people do because i have
donkey tools loaded a lot which has all
kinds of random things on the context
path
making sense yes yeah that makes sense
yes i was going to complain again about
the opposite problem
where i'm trying to debug something in
alpha and i don't remember the name of
the private symbol
and autocomplete refuses to go inside
backtick private backtick
right which you you can turn off that
that's a that's a
i don't know why it refuses to do it
listen we have the wrong people to
discuss this
i know it i know why it refuses to do it
and i'm telling you that the reason it
refuses to do it
is because you complained about it so
tom turned that off by default
okay so it's probably a mistake a front
end option
in order to allow that okay so listen
listen
the thing is if it isn't on the context
path it should not show it by default
if it is something that you start typing
in
i don't see why you shouldn't show it
it is not obvious to me that if i type
internal
in in this case here right that
right so how many private contacts do i
want to see
there i don't think i need to see them i
don't think i need to see anything
nested
at this point i'm just auto completing
so just auto complete me to the end of
that
that part of the context right and
that's all it will do
yeah that's that's what it does right
now now try the following
do system backtick private backtick
well what what's this private
backtick right so you have
the the option your
option which hides that which was right
so this is wrong
this is wrong this was a this was a a
fix to the wrong thing
this was the wrong fix to the other
problem that we had
we should change this but let's please
bring this up in a user assistance
meeting okay with the right people
but i think it's wrong right now i think
we we took a sledgehammer to this
because we couldn't get the heuristic
right
and it's and what's there is wrong
let's let's move on um
do we know now what to do with system
i well i guess my inclination is is to
not consider it internal
by default because it that that is the
more
compatible view but what do you mean not
considered internal we can't if there's
a system function
that has code i mean
is it the case that we have adopted the
discipline of setting read protected
whenever it is a blob of code that would
be
again the reason to not save the
definition is because it's going to get
reproduced again
on the on the destination end
right well i mean the problem the
problem is we have
both cases in in
in system right so for example
you know if you make changes to
right if you assign definitions to say
derivative then you probably want to
save them
but if you you know if if your
definition
uh pulls in dollar time zone
right well dollar time zone is not
protected because we want users to
set it but then if you pull it in
then you're when that's restored you're
going to have the
wrong time zone wrong time zone probably
yes right and so the question is
which is worse to sometimes pull in
unnecessary things or sometimes
not pull in things that the user wanted
saved is the symbol set the system
symbol set that we
to eat specially small enough that we
could just hack it together
probably let's look at that
let's look at system symbols that
realistically
i mean let's let's let's ask that
question that's a good that's a good
question
and maybe that could be either just now
in documentation and in the future some
kind of attribute
right so um i mean let's pick a random
area
okay it's just like
like if somebody resets something that
would desolve
i don't know i mean i don't think it
would be terrible if we didn't
pull that over we didn't save it well we
wouldn't
because d solve is protected
okay so here's a question which symbols
do i need to run this which symbols do
not have
so if protected say um names
oops oh
shoot i am running something which is
going to
which is refusing to stop roman
i have a parallel thing i'm trying to
interrupt it and it refuses to interrupt
well i mean that depends a lot on what
you're doing i mean
because that's what i'm doing i mean if
if
if those things take minutes or
they do longer then well
i i killed the remote kernels because
but it still won't release itself yes
now i mean you've seen that
earlier that there is a state where
if it's reading trying to read from a
remote kernel and you interrupt it then
you cannot interrupt it that's this
threaded interrupt doing link read
which i'm not responsible for well but
how is it going to get fixed
well it's apparently
not it's apparently by design and
but all i know is the only way to get
out of it is to kill the curler
sounds like that's something we should
pick up somewhere else
yeah i mean yeah i mean that's that's
john furrier
john and and todd because this has to do
with the math link contract
right fair enough
i mean the the bottom line is it's
causing one to have non-interruptible
parallel stuff and that's bad
but okay so now i can probably actually
run my name
star and oh
boy okay so do i really
my god what's going on here um
do i really need to do this so i think i
can do attributes on the string name
can't i
um yeah
i just ran it it's just that the whole
thing is too large to send it in chat
okay but so so it's
i mean oh yes freaky
free cube protected
some of these are bugs and read
protected right
no just protected okay right so a bunch
of those are things we can ignore
because right there they're typesetting
right there they're operators without
built-in meaning so if the user
gives some meaning then we want to keep
it right
okay but so so some of these might be
i mean why auto match isn't protected i
have no idea
i don't even know what auto match is
probably an option
i mean look at this the burn bound
saunders distribution this is kind of
embarrassing
that there are bugs here yeah just
straight bugs
so it looks like the statistics team
doesn't know to do this
for some function so this is let's send
this to qa
let's to me eyeballing this
yeah data you know
yeah i i wonder if this is an auto
loading issue
that they uh you know these
haven't auto loaded yet or some such and
they have stubs but nothing else or
something
anyway look this is a qasu but to me the
the immediate
thought is it would be okay to say
we will save system stuff if the system
is not put if the symbol is not
protected
and we will not otherwise okay
and that would mean we save derivative
we don't save
you know other things if you unprotect
okay so question is if you dynamically
unprotected something then maybe we
should save that
right okay so it's like we just look at
it we see if it's protected
let's try that but let's let's get qa to
look through this
and get this cleaned up okay
okay hold applied
right so there there are two sets of
issues with this idea
um i'm not i'm you know i'm not
convinced that this
is super useful but you
you've mentioned variants of this idea
multiple time
so one is the language design right we
need to somehow hold some values
so the question is so there's the
language design like
do we just have like a sub values
inherited
holding i mean that's not the right name
but you know
something which set right you'd need to
apply both this attribute
and you know hold all hold first hold
rest
and that would apply both to the symbol
and to the sub values
or do we have like three
you know hold all sub values hold first
sub hold sub value first whole
some value rest and
does that even make sense when you're
talking about sort of multiple levels of
sub values
and then there are the implementation
issues that well so one very obvious
issue is
hold applied f x y
what does it hold
right well it's going to apply it's
going to hold
x and y for sure i mean whatever
happens to x the same will happen to y i
think that's
that's inevitable okay so let me tell
you my perspective on this
what hold does having now spent a bunch
of time
studying evaluation orders in
these things like combinators and so on
we basically have
two evaluation schemes one is depth
first the other is essentially breadth
first which is the hold case
you know in other words it either goes
and evaluates
this is an evaluation control
essentially
right which order is the evaluation
going to happen in
for making sense and i know
that there's a whole zoo of different
evaluation orders
which people do not understand very well
but there's a zoo of different ones
and in fact there's a sort of an
arbitrary collection of of what is
evaluated first
and maybe what the way we should think
about this is a different language
design mechanism
which is more i mean i don't know
whether this makes any sense but
but let's imagine that we had something
like um
controlled evaluate
okay and then we said f x
y and then we said
this is the order in which i want this
to be evaluated part
two followed by part 1 followed by
the head followed by all meaning the
actual function
just as a you know as an alternative
idea
that it's a yes well i would say this
i would say this is sort of a much
cleaner idea i mean i'm not sure
right i mean i think we need some some
sort of family of rules
right named families yes yes
and in fact but yes i i think this is a
much
sort of cleaner design because right
this is kind of amusing we could
actually do things like this you know we
could actually use the named evaluation
schemes
so by outermost you mean top rat and
bottom
top right well so so just to give a
sense of this let me see if i can find
it
um um
i admit that this is very obscure stuff
this is combinators
some place here i talked about
it's also like tree visitors
yes it is i mean it is true to us
uh it's more than that it's not quite
tree traversal it has
it has some other tentacles to it
there's a tree traversal
implicit in your left most outermost but
you're right yes
there's okay left most outermost depth
first left most outermost et cetera et
cetera et cetera i think i have a table
here
of some of the common ones i mean these
are
this by the way these are multi-way
systems that show all possible updating
orders
of which there are many right and
leftmost outermost and so on it's just
one that can be labeled easily
here we go
there there's there's some of the zoo
should you have a non-deterministic
well that's also a possibility right i
mean so but this
do you understand that this is an
ordering these are
possible part numbers okay yep
and this is which one to do first
honestly this does make the most sense
it's just to give that list of part
numbers
and just basically give it in this form
here or give
a a rule okay so this is an interesting
idea
okay this is an interesting idea let's
say that we said
um ordered evaluate let's say
or something okay and then we have an
expression here
this is actually finally an idea that
makes sense some sense
um the okay so we say ordered evaluate
and then we have an expression here
and then we basically have a
um a a part
function a part part sorting function
and basically what happens is we find
without evaluating expo we find
all of its parts all the parts that
appear in expo
okay then this thing here sorts those
parts in order
and says which one should be evaluated
first and so on
see what i'm saying it gives the
evaluation order
great based on part numbers but you
don't just evaluate atoms you you
evaluate
whole things no no it's right right so
what happened
but what happens if the evaluation of a
part
sort of changes the
the right uh the i understand yeah right
changes the part well i think
there's a whole i if if one reads what's
written here
that there's some discussion of this
yeah i mean some of them can be done
recursively right then it's not a
problem but if you all
always look at the whole list of parts
then you would have to reevaluate that
ordering function after each
step right but i think that there's a
sense in which
in for some of these orderings there
will never be a
sub ordering so to speak in other words
the thing at the top of that tree if you
say evaluate the thing at the top of a
particular
tree it's like then you're doing
everything underneath
it see what i'm saying if you say
do part two then part two comma one and
part two comma two
they are sort of grandfathered or
something in
they are evaluated before two is
evaluated you always are evaluating the
subtree of a given part
in order to evaluate a part you always
evaluate its subtree anyway
and so the only way that you can have a
non-standard ordering
is if you go subtree before before full
tree if you
see what i mean so in other words if if
my ordering function
said i want to do part two comma one
then part two comma two then
part two yeah
right but if you put the two first we'd
have to delete the two one and two two
because
exactly they would nothing would happen
those would have been already done
yep actually i like this very much this
might be finally after 40 years because
i've been sort of meaning to do
it might actually be a way to do
controlled evaluation
wow that would be cool wow
so with that second argument in like
full generality be
like a full tree yeah be a list of part
numbers
i mean because i could imagine that you
know i want to evaluate part two before
part one
but within that you know i want to do
you know the second one before the first
part again
which i guess you can see
the thing is in this particular thing
this is a one pass this is
what it will do is hold exper and start
poking at exper
and saying evaluate this piece evaluate
that part piece
right now i guess what i was thinking
would be specified as like 2 2
comma 2 1 comma 2 comma 1.
that's fine that would be perfectly fine
so
okay ignorant okay we probably want the
same thing also for
uh replacement whole replacement right
not only for evaluation
you mean slash dot yes i mean well some
some variant of slash dot yes
that's a really good point yeah i mean
this might be finally the solution of of
traversal order
yeah you know we've been and map could
do the same thing
i mean map needs a traversal order as
well
traversal order is the general this sort
of suggests that maybe what we need is
not a new function but
a new a new spec if you will
like traversal order of blood that we
could stick into map and
exactly replace and well you're
suggesting that there's a traversal
order wrapper around an expression
as which as opposed to an option to map
for traversal order and i agree that a
traversal order wrapper
makes more sense because it is referring
to that expression
i was suggesting it not around the
expression but around the
the level spec right because the level
spec
is a kind of transformation i should
just say
yeah okay something like that all right
this is a very interesting
idea all right i have to go um
okay i mean is this is this a very
simple thing no
i mean it's a it's a i mean it's a
concise summary
but right it's about you know temporary
files
like so sort of more less temporary than
the ones we were talking about on monday
but
more but less temporary than things you
just stick in
slash temp because for example you might
want it to be
for the duration of decession okay
i need to go okay good stuff all right
talk to y'all soon